hey guys today it is the 23rd of July my
name is Jess McDowell and I have a bunch
of news for you so he is about three
minutes of them first up and in good
news for those of us who don't have an
xbox one square enix has confirmed that
rise of the Tomb Raider will make its
way over to ps4 and PC in 2016 while the
publisher still hasn't revealed specific
release date for these platforms they
have said that rise of the Tomb Raider
will be out on pc in early 2016 and on
ps4 during the holiday season of next
year there's been no mention of a ps3
version but the xbox one and xbox 360
versions being published by Microsoft
are on track to release this year on
November 10 square enix's clarified that
the game will be a console exclusive for
one year after its initial launch next
up it turns out they're trying to
implement backwards compatibility it's
really really hard for you Microsoft a
director of program management my kubera
said in an interview with xbox wire we
knew it would be an enormous engineering
challenge and many people told us it
would be impossible the xbox engineering
team apparently spent over three years
working on the functionality and you
Barra adders at a fundamental level we
believe that consumers should be able to
play their content on the devices they
aren't Microsoft is currently testing
the backwards compatibility feature for
Xbox preview program members before it
officially rolls out in the fall
stressing the difficulties of backwards
compatibility isn't the only thing that
Microsoft have been busying themselves
with the company are also cracking down
on violations of privacy in the form of
revenge porn in a pretty big way
following in the footsteps of companies
like Twitter and Google Microsoft are
now allowing victims of privacy
violations to remove intimate images of
themselves uploaded without their
consent from its cloud services onedrive
and Xbox Live the company has introduced
a web reporting form where users can
report instances of this happening
they're also willing to remove submit
Ariel from being search results the
company's chief online safety officer
Jacqueline bozhe explained in a blog
post we want to help put victims back in
control of their images and if privacy
let me know down in the comments which
platforms you'd want to play rise of the
Tomb Raider on and what you think of the
wait times you can add against that
we've got news UNAIDS fallout anthology
and a pretty impressive destiny beat
that is everything I wanted to tell you
about today but do join me same time
tumor for my top five stories of the
whole gaming week I will catch you in